Stanford University.
The Biomedical Engineering
Certificate is quite a wide-ranging certificate. It has a focus on imaging, and there are several different imaging
modalities that we will cover and
there's also a strong focus on a new
paradigm, which is implantable devices.
Hello. I'm Olav Solgaard. I'm here to tell you about our new
graduate certificate program in
biomedical engineering.
Biomedical engineering of the type of time you gonna learn about in this certificate program
really could have an impact on
a population that requires to be
constantly monitored. That's sort of
the low hanging fruit if you like.
It's a very multi-disciplinary type of
certificate. It has in some cases a very
strong focus on the electrical
engineering and image sharing, but also
on bio. The underlying principles are
however, that we're going to learn how to
interact with the body in new ways.
Ways that allows us to understand
how medical care should really be done
on a more personalized level. People who
would benefit from this are people who
are interested in things like
personalized health, or improving our healthcare system.
So you can choose your own
program here to tailor it to your needs
and to your interest.